[Música]
al menos 23 fallecidos y cerca de 70
heridos dejó el colapso de un tramo del
metro en ciudad de mexico el paso
elevado cayó sobre una calle transitada
aplastando autos bajo vagones caídos las
tareas de rescate fueron suspendidas
mientras se estabiliza la estructura con
una grúa y se retiran vagones que
quedaron colgando
en colombia a pesar del retiro del
proyecto de reforma tributaria continúan
las manifestaciones ciudadanas y
enfrentamientos con la fuerza pública en
varias ciudades del país por sexto día
consecutivo en cali la oficina de la onu
para los derechos humanos en colombia
denunció disparos de policías contra
miembros de su misión
y en el bicentenario de la muerte de
napoleón bonaparte france24 trae una
serie de informes especiales sobre su
vida y acciones políticos militares hoy
hablamos sobre las leyes con las que
llevó a francia a ser el único país del
mundo en restablecer la esclavización
regresamos con la actualización de las
noticias y vamos directamente a ciudad
de mexico porque colapsó un tramo
elevado del metro sobre una vía
transitada los vagones aplastaron
automóviles y hasta ahora se cuentan al
menos 23 muertos y cerca de 70 heridos
el ejército llegó a la zona para ayudar
con las tareas vamos a los detalles con
nuestro corresponsal mario carbón el
buen día para usted de mario y en la
madrugada se suspendieron los trabajos
porque la estructura estaba inestable en
qué va eso
buen día así es durante la madrugada
llegaron grúas de alto tonelaje
precisamente para poder sacar los
últimos cuerpos que estaban atrapados
luego de que se desplomó este vagón del
metro como bien lo comentas fueron al
menos tres personas las que fueron de
último momento rescatadas sin vida por
lo que ya están contabilizadas en los 23
muertos ya no hay más personas atrapadas
de acuerdo con las autoridades de
protección civil siguen los trabajos
para bajar estos vagones a la tierra y
poderlos retirar del lugar la jefa de
gobierno ha dicho que pues se iniciará
una investigación profunda y una
revisión estructural de toda la línea
que por cierto está cerrada en su
totalidad son 20 estaciones que
permanecen cerradas y se han dispuesto
490 autobuses para dar atención a los
pasajeros en esa zona de la ciudad al
oriente de la ciudad fueron 5 metros de
caída este paso elevado solamente tenía
una década
mario han adelantado algo las
autoridades de la causa del accidente
han dicho que van a realizar peritajes y
de ser necesario se haría una migración
externa
lo cierto es que ésta
con múltiples fallas desde su
inauguración en 2012 hubo incluso la
necesidad de cerrar
11 estaciones de esta línea en marzo de
2014 porque presentaban fallas de
compatibilidad entre los rieles y las
ruedas asimismo tras el sismo de 2017
hubo daños en las columnas que soportan
este paso elevado por lo que también
permanecieron cerradas algunas
situaciones para darle mantenimiento y
rehabilitar estas columnas
sin embargo presentaban las fallas
continuas en 2020 los usuarios de redes
sociales habitantes de la zona habían
mostrado como estaba desnivelado
precisamente un tramo en este en este en
este periodo de la línea 12 del metro y
pues simplemente no se atendió por lo
visto porque se desplomó por completo
esta a través que se llaman ballenas y
los resultados ahí están se harán los
trabajos de reparación pero sobre todo
las investigaciones gracias a ustedes
mario y seguimos con más noticias en
colombia continúan las protestas
ciudadanas
el gobierno de iván duque tras días de
manifestaciones callejeras que se
lograron retirar del proyecto de reforma
tributaria ahora la gente pide justicia
por al menos 19 fallecidos desde el
inicio del paro nacional el 28 de abril
en cali una de las ciudades más
afectadas se registró una nueva noche de
enfrentamientos y la representante de la
onu en colombia denunció ataques y
disparos contra la comisión
mientras dábamos seguimiento a la
situación de derechos humanos en cali no
hubo disparos directos contra el equipo
de la onu de derechos humanos sin
embargo otros miembros de la comisión
recibieron amenazas y agresiones así
como disparos por parte de la policía
sin que nadie resultara impactado
estamos sumamente preocupados por la
información que estamos recibiendo a
esta hora sobre un número no confirmado
de personas muertas y heridas en cali
llamamos al respeto por la vida de todas
las personas solo así se fortalecerá la
democracia y el estado de derecho y
precisamente este lunes distintos
colectivos indígenas se sumaron a las
protestas en cali principal epicentro
del estallido social colombiano nuestros
enviados especiales luís muñoz y juan
carlos zapatas estuvieron acompañando a
la minga durante todo el día esto fue lo
que vieron
y 1.500 indígenas venidos de distintos
territorios se concentran en la
universidad del valle están decidiendo
qué van a hacer si marchan a protestar a
bogotá a la capital o si se quedan en
cali son la conocida como minga la minga
social y comunitaria es una minga que ha
caído muy bien en la opinión nacional
puesto que fortalece el ejercicio de la
democracia porque allí en la minga no
hay presidentes no hay jefes no hay casi
que ser la minga es el colectivo
entre los indígenas de la minga está
feliciano valencia senador de la
república de colombia se dirige a sus
compañeros cuenta que en los territorios
llevan décadas de resistencia
el pueblo colombiano se está moviendo a
pesar de que los medios masivos dicen
que la concentración está en medellín en
bogotá y en cali las veredas los
corregimientos las cabeceras municipales
las vías prácticamente están movilizadas
y bloqueadas en este momento la mina
siempre va acompañada de la guardia
indígena son los encargados de la
seguridad de las comunidades están
acostumbrados a defenderse de grupos
ilícitos paramilitares narcotraficantes
guerrilleros e incluso de la fuerza
pública detrás de nosotros pues han
caído muchos compañeros guardias han
sido asesinados por los diferentes
grupos armados entonces eso nos motiva y
nos llena más de fortaleza para seguir
resistiendo en todos los espacios y en
todos los escenarios
la vida decide salir a las calles de
cali consideran que es el epicentro de
la resistencia de colombia uno de sus
líderes comunica que saben cuándo llegan
pero no cuando vuelven un compromiso que
se vuelve grito el grito de la mina
[Música]
y con motivo del bicentenario de la
muerte del soldado general y emperador
francés napoleón bonaparte que se
conmemorará el próximo miércoles 5 de
mayo 324 les trae una serie de informes
especiales sobre su vida y las acciones
del histórico político y militar en el
siguiente informe nos acercamos uno en
uno en los episodios más dramáticos de
la historia de francia
buena parte restauró la esclavitud en
sus colonias de américa latina'
3 de febrero de 1802 los barcos del
general sal virtual emanuel lukla
desembarcan en santo domingo su cuñado
napoleón bonaparte primer cónsul lado de
órdenes muy claras retomar la colonia
francesa dirigida por tus sanlu bertso
por que napoleón ha tomado una decisión
que pretende hacer cumplir restablecer
la esclavitud de las colonias francesas
era casi seguro que tan pronto como
llegara al poder había un plan para
restablecer el antiguo sistema colonial
es decir la esclavitud es de dos estados
la esclavitud fue abolida por la
convención de la revolución francesa en
1794 pero cuando napoleón bonaparte
llegó al poder tenía un objetivo
restaurar el imperio colonial francesa
en américa y explotar al máximo sus
recursos ya no lo vi hay un lobby los
colonos los armadores sus comerciantes o
fabricantes que piensan que la vuelta a
la esclavitud significaría el regreso de
la riqueza y la prosperidad en santo
domingo los combates continúan
jean-jacques dessalines sucesor de
tussam lo vertió derrota a las tropas de
buena parte y fundó
[Música]
es este recuerdo grabado en el corazón
la cabeza y el alma de todos los
haitianos eso es lo que recuerdan de
napoleón el que quería restablecer la
esclavitud y contra el que las tropas de
los que van descalzos del santo domingo
como se llamaban a sí mismos tomaron las
armas y derrotaron a las tropas de la
nieve de wikileaks visión en 1802 otra
colonia se rebeló guadalupe pero aquí la
revuelta fracasó y la esclavitud se
restableció en la isla que sigue siendo
un departamento francés las
conmemoraciones del bicentenario de la
muerte de napoleón despiertan un
recuerdo muy doloroso
hoy todos tenemos el deber de exigir la
rehabilitación de nuestros antepasados y
que se respeten nuestra historia que no
se reescriba la historia simplemente por
la gloria de un hombre de lyon por sus
leyes y decretos de 1802 napoleón
convirtió francia en el único país del
mundo en haber restablecido la
esclavitud después de haberla abolido es
el final del informativo pero regresamos
en minutos con más sigue en france 24 y
en france 24 punto com
[Música]